sérieuses incertitudes politiques en
asie après la disparition de kim il sung
le dictateur communiste a régné sans
partage durant près d'un demi siècle sur
la corée du nord
la réunion du g7 à naples 200 millions
de dollars débloqués en faveur des
ukrainiens pour financer la fermeture de
la centrale nucléaire de tchernobyl au
rwanda le chef du gouvernement
intérimaire reconnaît la victoire
militaire du front patriotique alors que
les généraux de l'armée gouvernementale
publié un appel à la réconciliation
nationale la disparition du cinéaste
christian jacq le réalisateur entre
autres de fanfan la tulipe et ce dernier
titre la qualification de l'italie pour
la demi finale de la coupe du monde vous
venez de le vivre en direct sur france 2
madame monsieur bonsoir la presse de son
pays le qualifier alternativement deux
grands leaders de chefs génial et bien
aimé de héros bienfaiteur du peuple ou
encore de soleil de la corée kim il sung
est mort à 82 ans après avoir régné sans
partage sur la corée du nord durant 46
ans record mondial de longévité au
pouvoir
cet empereur entre guillemets communiste
était l'un des personnages les plus
secrets et les plus inquiétants de
l'histoire contemporaine
stéphane magnier il adorait ses fêtes où
des milliers de petites filles animait
des tableaux humains
c'était le fruit d'une coordination
parfait comme celle que donne un peuple
embrigader depuis l'enfance sous la
férule implacable d'un dieu vivant kim
il sung avaient éradiqué toute
opposition
jusqu à l'ombre d'une contestation il
possède le culte de sa personnalité
encore plus loin peut-être que son
maître staline qui l'avait mis en place
en 1948
kim il sung bâti sa réputation en
faisant la première guerre de l'après
guerre celle de la conquête de la corée
du sud par le nord jusqu'à ce que les
américains interviennent pour amener la
frontière au 38e parallèle puis kim il
sung
l'esa lentement son pays glisser vers la
pauvreté et l'isolément absolu
privilégiant l'armée et la bombe
atomique sur la prospérité et la
démocratie il contrôlait tout
l'information l'école les frontières son
peuple est le seul au monde à ne rien
savoir de ce qui se passe ni chez lui ni
ailleurs il est aussi le seul au monde
qui verra naître une monarchie
communiste puisque kim il sung a choisi
son propre fils pour lui succéder
on vient de le dire qui minent son ya
donc créé la première dynastie
communiste au monde
son fils kim jong il à 50 ans n'est
jamais sorti de son pays et certains
redoutent qu'il soit tenté pour
préserver son pouvoir par une sorte de
fuite en avant en relançant le chantage
nucléaire mis en place par son père
olivier werner derrière son papa on le
voyait souvent applaudir des deux mains
kim junior
on va sans doute bientôt le voir à
l'oeuvre il dirigeait déjà le parti et
l'armée sans pour autant faire
l'unanimité
c'est bien pour ça qu'une certaine
inquiétude règne depuis ce matin en
corée du nord et la gauche passer au
moins 20 c au barabao tout est fermé
tout est désespérée
alors c'est ça qui fait peur alors
certainement dans un mois dans deux mois
on va avoir un peu plus clair mais c'est
à moi au des mois ou trois mois
ce sera extrêmement important non
seulement aux rapports entre le nord et
le sud mais aussi pour le monde entier
il y a trois semaines à peine jimmy
carter salué tout sourire le président
nord-coréen
une image qui n'était pas passée
inaperçue aux états unis carter chargé
d'obtenir un gel permanent du programme
nucléaire nord-coréen
en échange de quoi il y aurait
reconnaissance diplomatique et
l'assistance économique
il ya eu des toute l'ailé pure je pars
avec elle et l'a éliminé physiquement
tous ses adversaires politiques et tout
le régime qu'il a créée la coupé du
monde extérieur qui freinait
complètement le développement du pays et
qu'elle essayait de sauver son régime
par tous les moyens y compris donc
actuellement par le chantage nucléaire
le chantage appartient peut-être au
passé 12 informations confirment un
changement d'attitude
le sommet prévu pour le 25 juillet
prochain entre les deux corées est
confirmée et puis américains et coréens
du nord vont poursuivre leurs
discussions sur le nucléaire à genève
kim jong il n'est peut être pas le fils
à papa qu'on croit la guerre au rwanda
les combattants du front patriotique
reste toujours à la limite de la zone
humanitaire créée par les français dans
le sud ouest du pays
le grand problème reste plus que jamais
la plus dramatique de réfugiés dans
cette zone
eric lemasson ils sont des dizaines de
milliers silencieux et apeurés ils
fuient des réfugiés hutus qui fuit
l'avancée des troupes du fpr en faisant
route vers l'ouest vers la frontière du
zaïre vers espère t-il un peu de
sécurité
ces images ont été tournées hier nous
sommes arusha chi 40 km à l'ouest de
kigali dans la dernière zone encore
contrôlée par les forces
gouvernementales ou tout la seule région
du rwanda ou le fpr peut encore avancer
les français n'ont pour l'instant pas
l'intention d'en assurer le contrôle
leur zone de sécurité se situe plus au
sud
ici aucune organisation humanitaire ne
vient encore en aide à cette population
qui s'accumulent trop vite pour que
quiconque n'ait le temps d'organiser des
secours ces réfugiés s'entassent trombe
bientôt le long de la frontière à iroise
et selon les militaires français
au total ce sont un million deux cent
mille euros an dès qu'ils sont ainsi
poussés sur les routes par la crainte de
nouveaux massacres
sur le plan politique l'émissaire des
nations unies et sur place a rencontré
aujourd'hui des représentants du
gouvernement intérimaire pour négocier
un cessez le feu
n'y aura peut-être pas besoin de trêve
au rwanda faute de combattants
les militaires encore fidèles au
gouvernement intérimaire semble en effet
le lâcher des officiers parmi les plus
influents de l'armée gouvernementale
viennent en effet de publier une
déclaration solennelle appelant à la
réconciliation nationale
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux benoît
duquesne jean louis normandin jean paul
votron cet homme un général de brigade
il a surtout été pendant des années aux
côtés du président assassiné à berryman
a d'abord au ministre de la défense
ensuite à la présidence
aujourd'hui ils commandent l'école
supérieur militaire de kigali repliées
près de wikango raw et pour la première
fois il parle et signe un texte avec
d'autres officiers supérieurs
une sorte d'appel où il est question
d'arrêt des combats de négociation avec
le fpr et de condamnation du génocide
n'en déplaise au gouvernement de plus en
plus provisoire de guissény la
différence entre la production du
helmand est la nôtre et consistait à ce
que de l'intérieur
nous dénonçons nous et nous condamnons
officiellement génocide et tous les
autres crimes qui ont été commis dans un
seul pays
il ya eu assez de mots assez de
destruction c'est eux étaient qu'attendu
mais que matérielles et il faut que la
guerre finisse pour reconcile le pays
mais quel est le poids de ce général et
de son arme et d'adolescents dans une
zone où ses troupes ne se bat plus une
zone dont seuls les français exploit
encore tiers pour constater l'avancée du
fpr
à la frontière à frontière
il faut pas s'attarder ici pourquoi la
casse
pourquoi forcément victimes des civils
qui continue d'affluer par centaines de
milliers dans la zone française dans la
tente d'une aide humanitaire qui tarde à
arriver
le sommet du g7 réunis à naples
souffrent de gastro-entérite aiguë le
nouveau ministre premier ministre
japonais nommé pourtant il ya une
semaine à peine a dû abandonner ses six
collègues qui se sont penchés
aujourd'hui sur le dollar qui montre lui
aussi de sérieux accès de faiblesse
depuis quelques temps mais aussi sur le
chômage et l'inflation
le point avec l'anneau envoyés spéciaux
à naples philippe sassier la première
partie du sommet de naples g7 économique
s'est terminé ce soir sur un résultat
qui est qualifié ici de satisfaisant
voix j'ai trouvé ce sommet
particulièrement positif d'abord par
l'état d'esprit des participants le
désir d'aboutir de confirmer des
positions plus ancien c'est le cas pour
l'emploi pour parvenir à diminuer le
nombre des chômeurs 24 millions dans les
sept pays présents à naples plusieurs
actions sont prescrites améliorer la
formation initiale développer
l'apprentissage encourager la formation
permanente éliminer les excès de
réglementations encourager les
technologies nouvelles
aider les petites et moyennes
entreprises on retrouve là des pistes
explorées au sommet mondial sur l'emploi
à détroit au mois de mars dernier
et puis après des discussions parfois
laborieuse les sept se sont également
entendus sur un plan financier pour
arrêter et reconstruire tchernobyl ils
ont rappelé tout en restant assez
discret l'importance de la clause
sociale dans le commerce international
enfin l'aide aux pays en voie de
développement fait l'objet d'un chapitre
important les sept pays les plus riches
vont accroître le montant des
annulations de dettes des pays les plus
pauvres
et puis les chefs d'état de gouvernement
se sont bien gardés de parler de mode et
mais leurs ministres des finances ont
déclaré que le dollar n'avait aucune
raison de baisser alors ils vont
renforcer leur coopération économique
mais ils ont décidé de ne pas dépenser
un centime pour lutter contre la
spéculation
si vous asseyez a fait allusion les
dirigeants du g7 se sont penchés sur le
dossier tchernobyl en proposant aux
ukrainiens une aide immédiate de 200
millions de dollars pour financer la
fermeture définitive de cette centrale
les ukrainiens réclame beaucoup plus
d'argent mais les sept leur ont promis
un accès facile à des financements
internationaux
le point du dossier avec josé blanc la
pierre voici le cadeau du g7 à l'ukraine
lui donner les moyens d'achever cette
centrale nucléaire en construction mais
pour remplacer tchernobyl c'est à dire 7
% de l'énergie du pays
il faut plus que ça les 4 milliards de
francs donnés par le g7 à l'ukraine vont
donc servir à terminer les travaux de
trois réacteurs en construction dans le
pays
trois réacteurs de conception moderne a
priori moins dangereux mais surtout
soumis au contrôle des autorités
nucléaires européennes
c'est dans ces conditions que tchernobyl
pour affirmer si possible d'ici 1996 en
contrepartie l'ukraine doit s'engager à
réformer sa politique énergétique en
priorité elle doit lutter contre le
gaspillage inciter la population à faire
des économies
augmenter la facture du chauffage urbain
enfin utiliser d'autres sources
d'énergie de son côté l'ukraine jouent
aux marchands de tapis
d'après michael ou magnette il faudra 30
ans pour rayer de tchernobyl de la carte
le patron du nucléaire ukrainiens
estiment aussi que la refonte de la
politique énergétique du pays demandera
au moins 30 milliards de francs et que
pour sauver l'ukraine c'est six nouveaux
réacteurs qu'il lui faut aujourd'hui
dans sa déclaration le g7 a consenti des
prêts supplémentaires à l'ukraine
jusqu'à 22 milliards de francs en france
nouveau marathon législatif à
l'assemblée nationale avec la discussion
du projet de loi défendu par charles
pasqua sur la politique de développement
du territoire un projet suivi de très
près par les députés qui ont pour la
plupart un autre mandat local
face aux réserves de la majorité aux
critiques de l'opposition
le ministre de l'intérieur s'est déclaré
prêt aux concessions sébastien fuit vers
jean pierre balligand ne se sent
vraiment à l'aise que sur son territoire
et son territoire c'est vers 20 petit
bourg rural de l'aisne 3000 habitants 14
% de chômage bref jean pierre balligand
est un élu local
et comme élu local il a sa petite idée
sur l'aménagement du territoire
son truc attirer les entreprises en
milieu rural et il est tout fier de
présenter la société qui s'est installé
sur sa commune pour lui la solution ne
doit pas toujours venir d'en haut
tout n'est pas affaire de subventions
l'aménagement du territoire c'est clair
peut pas être artificiel on peut pas
mettre sous perfusion
le monde rural il faut l'aider dans ses
projets dans des vrais projets des
projets qui créent la richesse et donc
qui créent des optiques jean pierre
balligand est monté au créneau à
l'assemblée ce n'est donc pas seulement
parce qu'il est dans l'opposition c'est
aussi parce qu'il estime que certains
articles du projet pasqua ne sont pas
assez concret pas assez décentralisateur
sauf ce terrain il a l'appui de l'un de
ses adversaires politiques
jean françois mancel le patron du
département de l'oise soutient le texte
de charles pasqua
mais comme beaucoup dans la majorité ils
voudraient aller plus loin que l'état
s'occupe d'aménager le territoire c'est
bien mais régions départements et
communes ont aussi leur rôle à jouer
on ne doit pas oublier que les
collectivités locales sont des acteurs
très importants de l'aménagement du
territoire ça ce n'est pas aujourd'hui
dans le projet pasqua le milieu de
l'intérieur nous dit que ça sera l'objet
d'un autre texte
j'en suis tout à fait convaincu donc je
lui fais confiance sur ce point mais je
souhaite qu'on n'oublie pas car c'est
tout à fait essentiel charles pasqua a
semble-t-il bien reçu le message il
admet les réserves que son projet
suscite
il se dit même prêt à enrichir son texte
des propositions des députés avec le
cinéaste christian jacq mort rejoint à
l'âge de 89 ans à paris disparaît l'un
des réalisateurs les plus prolifiques du
cinéma populaire français christian jacq
a signé entre autres françois 1er avec
fernandel les disparus de saint-agil
avec michel simon
fanfan la tulipe avec gérard philipe ou
encore babette s'en va-t-en guerre avec
brigitte bardot jarre dalmas
on aura un supplice de la chaîne avec
bien ce tabac entre les orteils de
fernandel christian jacq réussi à
transformer en bourreau la célèbre
chaîne le mari de martine carol hansell
architectes décorateurs sims en dix
films en préparant chaque scène comme on
construit une maison il tourne avec les
plus grands dont bourvil de 32 à 85 avec
erich von stroheim michel simon et le
jeune mouloudji les disparus de
saint-agil on peut être bien inspiré le
fameux cercle des poètes disparus
cinquante ans plus tard quatre ans
qu'ils l'auront populaire évidemment
fanfan la tulipe gestion jacques qui a
pratiqué tous les genres mais surtout
l'histoire avait beaucoup de tendresse
pour son héros épiques mais romantique
peut-être que plus tard tu penseras moi
c'est dire ah tiens oui cet écrivain jeu
c'était le papa de fanfan la tulipe
les chorégies d'orange début de ce soit
avec nabucco l'un des opéras les plus
populaires de verdi une oeuvre qui avait
enflammé le coeur des italiens lors de
sa création siècle dernier reportage
georges bigot daniel defert est finie
pelouse y
la solennité du théâtre antique d'orange
se prête idéalement au nabucco de verdi
dans l'action commence à jérusalem
devant les murailles du temple de
salomon
et
ouais
kheraj tâche énorme il s'agit de trois
quarts ensemble avignon au roi et nice
ils sont travaillés être heureux mais
c'est très dur parce qu'elle y est
terrible de lui et ses immenses on peut
vraiment lié nabucco le tour d'italie le
peuple qui souffre et qui obtiennent sa
chaire d'études de sa victoire
ça c'est sûr histoire de sentiments purs
définitif est simple elles obtiennent
par la sérénité par la vérité parler du
ciel des sources youn a le sentiment
religieux sans religion mais par la
force des sentiments et verdi à bienne
interpréter les sentiments du peuple
verdict connu la gloire aussitôt et son
nom de 20 synonyme de liberté
le tour de france plus que jamais
cosmopolite c'est un slovaquie a
remporté l'étape du futuroscope devant
un ouzbek ce qui a permis à un belge de
reprendre le maillot jaune à un anglais
précision et christophe duchiron un
champ c'est monsieur avoir sa tête il a
dû lutter conclure sur le vélo le belge
musée pourtant le jaune il va bien mais
ça ne le rend pas d'un mot rigolard le
belge musée il a profité du matin calme
pour rappeler 4 secondes de
bonifications derrière le maillot vert
d'abuja par offre quatre secondes ça lui
suffit à lui la tunique jaune que
portait sa nièce l'angle italien
politain coureurs honnêtes
l'italien au lit il est comme tout le
monde pas le genre à se refuser un petit
plaisir en solitaire
il a même fait dans la longueur 166 km
seul et jusqu'à 17 minutes d'avancé au
maximum de sa forme italien pour lui
porter joli prénom
il s'appelle heroes seulement voilà
petit à petit le peloton réagit la vente
le polyshow au soleil km 226 le peloton
reprend colis vous avais prévenu polita
trouvera honnête il le prouve
au revoir les amis pour le reste c'est
presque comme d'habitude un peloton
groupé pour l'exécution du sprint final
à poitiers les sprinteurs ne se met pas
martel en tête il fonce et ça fait des
vagues
ludwig à gauche aurait pu gagner abuja
par up à droite aurait pu gagner mais
c'est ce mot radar au centre qui
l'emportent
le radar de florac a vu la victoire
jours plus tard capelle le meilleur
français avant le cinquième et courait
au classement général 1 belge savons
qu'un anglais de la place de leader
vu les écarts le belge sera peut-être
plus en jeu demain
après tout on verra bien la coupe du
monde de football vient de redémarrer au
quart de tour prendre le match
qualificatif pour les demi-finales
italie espagne que vous venez de vivre
en direct sur france 2 et qui s'est
achevé sur le score de 2 à 1 en faveur
de l'italie qui accède donc ainsi en
demi finale aux dépens de l'espagne deux
buts des frères pas des frères d2 baggio
exactement après les voiles de la
liberté qui avait fêté en 89 le
bicentenaire de la révolution
rouen célèbre cette année un autre
tournant décisif de notre histoire
le cinquantenaire du débarquement en
accueillant l'armada de la liberté les
plus beaux voiliers du monde
accompagné d'une vingtaine de navires de
guerre
regarde marins sur une escale unique
ce sont les cadets de la mairie covès
putsch est le fier trois-mâts italien
l'un des plus beaux grands voiliers du
monde
avec les dorures et ses bois précieux
ses 101 mètres de long le trois-mâts
barque est un géant d'élégance et le
sait
amerigo guatemala eagle esmeralda leur
nom claque
ils disent l'écumé le vent l'histoire
maritime des siècles derniers laventure
les plus beaux navires du monde ont
remonté ce matin les boucles de la seine
pour un défilé hors du temps car les
princes des océans aime se faire admirer
et les quais de rouen tout au bout du
voyage leur offre une scène
exceptionnelle
les amoureux de la marine à voile sont
au rendez vous ils sont venus à rouen
chercher leur part de rêve embarqués ne
serait ce que quelques minutes seulement
à bord d'un grand voilier
j'ai fait mon service militaire dans la
marine bon je vais monter sur un voilier
bon ça évoque les grands espaces ruraux
tout témoin être marin quand tu seras
grand
m
demain d'autres navires encore viendront
s'amarrer au coeur de la ville une
escale pour remonter le temps 20h33
l'heure pour moi de mettre les voiles et
de laisser la place au programme avec
dans quelques minutes de fort boyard
fort boyard suivi à 22h42 la reprise de
palace vers minuit le dernier journal
présenté par catherine ceylac dans un
instant la météo avec un ciel dominical
aussi lumineux que nathalie rihouet si
vous d'hier à demain 13h excellente
soirée sur france 2